monsieur le président de l'assemblée
générale monsieur le secrétaire général
des nations unies mesdames et messieurs
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement l'an
dernier nous étions réunis à new york
pour notre assemblée générale et
j'appelais alors chacun d'entre vous à
avoir le courage de bâtir la paix
d'exercer ensemble nos responsabilités
ce courage de le dire a été plus que
durement éprouvé par un choc sanitaire
économique social sécuritaire d'une
ampleur sans précédent d'une immédiate
globalité
depuis la création de notre organisation
il ya 75 ans et ce courage ce fut
d'abord celui de celles et ceux qui ont
été dès le premier jour en première
ligne
partout dans le monde et qu'ils le sont
encore aujourd'hui pour soigner nourrir
accompagné épauler tenir le soignant nos
personnels humanitaires
je veux en commençant ces quelques mots
penser à eux
ils attendent de nous que nous nous
engagions et que nous construisions des
réponses concrètes ensemble car cette
crise sans doute plus que tout qu'une
autre impose la coopération impose
d'inventer de nouvelles solutions
internationales d'abord je crois en la
science et en la connaissance et
l'humanité vaincre à cette pandémie un
remède sera trouvé mais dans cette
attente dont nul ne sait combien elles
durent à chacun de nos pays n'aura
d'autre choix que d'apprendre à vivre
avec le virus et le monde devra
apprendre à vivre avec cette nouvelle
réalité qui s'impose à tous révèlent nos
vulnérabilités nous place devant nos
immédiate responsabilité cette nouvelle
réalité mondiale est clair brutale
certainement vertigineuse et nous devons
la regarder sans nous laisser aller au
désespoir ni au découragement mais avec
lucidité tous les défis auxquels nous
étions confrontés ont été en quelques
mois
accentuer et aggravé les succès obtenus
ont été entravés et les reculs se sont
accumulés des années de progrès dans la
lutte contre les autres maladies
infectieuses comme le vih le paludisme
la tuberculose
dont nous pensions pouvoir venir à bout
a pris du retard parfois plus plus de 37
millions de personnes sont tombées ou
retomber dans l'extrême pauvreté
l'insécurité alimentaire menace
gravement et s'est accrue plus d'un
milliard d'élèves ont été touchés par la
fermeture des écoles dans plus de 160
pays
40 millions d'enfants n'ont pas pu
bénéficier de la première année de leur
éducation
les femmes ont été en première ligne ont
vu s'accumuler contre elles toutes les
formes de violence sexuelle domestique
de genre
face à cela et à tant d'autres
conséquences liées à la pandémie qui a
frappé notre planète et qui continuent
de toucher tous les continents
la fracturation de nos moyens d'action
collectif s'est accéléré alors même que
la seule solution viendra de notre
coopération
les organisations internationales dont
nous avons tant besoin comme
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ont
été accusés par les seins de
complaisance et instrumentalisé par les
autres les tiers de confiance
scientifiques journalistes si essentiel
pour comprendre et agir efficacement en
face à la crise ont été remis en cause
par la propagande des états comme par
l'épidémie de la désinformation
notre organisation elle-même a couru le
risque de l'impuissance
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
garant de la paix de la stabilité est
difficilement parvenu à s'entendre sur
une trêve humanitaire que nous avons
soutenu de toutes nos forces
imaginez le avoir tant de mal à nous
accorder sur sip
mais ses membres permanents n'ont pas pu
en des circonstances aussi exceptionnel
se réunir comme nous l'aurions voulu
parce que deux d'entre eux ont préféré à
l'efficacité collective l'affichage de
leur rivalité
toutes les fractures qui préexistait à
la pandémie
le choc hégémonique des puissances la
remise en cause du multilatéralisme son
instrumentalisation le piétinement du
droit international n'ont fait que
s'accélérer et s'approfondir à la faveur
de la déstabiliser
si on global créé par la pandémie nous
n'avons plus le droit de fermer les yeux
nous n'avons plus l'opportunité le luxe
si je puis dire de tergiverser cette
pandémie doit être pour notre
organisation un électrochoc et le moment
d'un réveil salvateur
c'est possible parce que dans cette
épreuve des motifs d'espérance sont
apparus l'union européenne dont beaucoup
quelque sorte prédisait la division et
l'impuissance à fait à la faveur de la
crise un pas historique d'unités de
souveraineté de solidarité de choix de
l'avenir c'est l'europe qui avec ses
partenaires africains a pris
l'initiative au g20 pour aider les pays
les plus vulnérables à faire face à la
pandémie et alléger le fardeau de la
dette qui pèse sur les économies et met
en péril l'avenir du continent pour la
première fois dans un g20 finances
nous avons acté d'un moratoire sur la
dette de ces pays les plus pauvres en
afrique c'est l'europe qui avec ses
partenaires a permis de construire
l'initiative acta pour que les moyens de
lutte contre la pandémie soit accessible
à tous c'est elle qui avec d'autres a
permis que l'assemblée mondiale de la
santé décide de tirer les leçons de la
pandémie et d'améliorer les systèmes
d'alerté de réaction précoce pour mieux
prévenir de telles crises c'est l'europe
qui avec d'autres partenaires en asie en
amérique en afrique a eu l'énergie de
construire de proposer de porter des
solutions concrètes de coopération de
solidarité et d'action il faudra compter
à l'avenir avec ces nouveaux équilibres
qui sont en train de se définir
il faudra compter sur la force des
bonnes volontés parce que le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ne peut pas se
résumer à la rivalité entre la chine et
les états unis quel que soit le poids
mondial de ces deux grandes puissances
quel que soit aussi l'histoire qui nous
lie en particulier aux états unis
d'amérique la crise
l'effondrement de nos craintes de nos
cadres de coopération les fragilités que
je viens d'évoquer nous impose de
rebâtir un nouvel ordre et impose à
l'europe de prendre toute sa part de
responsabilité c'est à dire de porter
ses valeurs son goût de l'avenir et de
savoir bâtir des solutions nouvelles
parce que nous ne sommes pas
collectivement condamné un pas de deux
qui en quelque sorte nous réduire à
n'être que les spectateurs désolé d'une
impuissance collective
nous avons des marges de manoeuvre
à nous de les utiliser et à nous de
savoir définir les priorités qui sont
les nôtres dans cet environnement de
poser avec clarté nos choix et de
construire des alliances nouvelle dans
les semaines et les mois à venir des
choix fondamentaux seront à opérer des
décisions à prendre devant nos peuples
devant la communauté internationale
et ces choix auront un impact immédiat
sur la vie de nos nations sur
l'existence de nos concitoyens sur la
marche du monde
nous ne devons pas nous dérober parce
que c'est précisément quand tout vacille
qu'il faut revenir à l'essentiel et je
crois très profondément que depuis le
début de cette crise du coc u19 ce n'est
pas une parenthèse qui s'est ouverte et
se refermerait c'est la poursuite d'un
monde traversée par des crises profondes
qui sont aussi dues à nos
interdépendances et il y aura sûrement
un jour un remède à la pandémie
mais il n'y aura pas de remède miracle
la déstructuration de l'ordre
contemporain il n'y aura pas de remède
miracle à cette espèce de paradoxes dans
lequel nous sommes plongés jamais nos
sociétés n'ont été aussi
interdépendantes et au moment même où
tout cela arrive jamais nous n'avons été
si désaccordé si d aligner six incapable
de construire des solutions rapides
si en situation nous mêmes les mêmes
parfois de détruire les cadres de
coopération que nous avons su créé
durant les dernières décennies
c'est pourquoi je tenais à dire devant
cette assemblée les cinq priorités sur
lesquelles la france souhaite compte
rire avec ses partenaires européens au
premier chef mais avec aussi toutes les
puissances de bonne volonté c'est à dire
avec tous ceux qui seront prêts à s'y
engager les fondations d'un nouveau
consensus contemporain qui nous
permettra d'agir concrètement dans le
monde tel qu'il est le premier principe
la première aube le premier objectif
c'est la lutte contre la prolifération
des armes de destruction massive et
contre le terrorisme qui menace au
premier chef notre sécurité collective
la stratégie de la pression maximale
engagé depuis plusieurs années n'a pas
permis à ce stade de mettre fin aux
activités déstabilisatrices de l'iran ni
de nous assurer qu'il ne pourra pas se
doter de l'armé nucléaire
c'est pourquoi la france qui vous vous
en souvenez mais pas le pays qui a
initié à l'époque la négociation puis
consul à cordes discipline mais la
france avec ses partenaires allemands et
britanniques maintiendra son exigence de
mise en oeuvre pleine et entière de
l'accord de vienne de 2015 et
n'acceptera pas les violations commises
par l'iran
nous ne transigerons pas pour autant sur
l'activation d'un mécanisme que les
etats-unis de leur propre chef en
sortant de l'accord ne sont pas en
situation d'activer ce serait porter
atteinte à l'unité du conseil de
sécurité à l'intégrité de ses décisions
et ce serait prendre le risque
d'aggraver encore les tensions dans la
région mais il nous faut bâtir dans la
durée un cadre d'action utile que je
rappeler dans notre assemblée générale
même il ya maintenant plus de deux ans
c'est à dire la capacité à compléter
l'accord de 2015 d'abord dans le temps
pour s'assurer que dans la durée
l'iran n'accédera jamais à l'arme
nucléaire mais aussi en assurant que
nous allons apporter les réponses à
l'activité balistiques de l'iran mais
aussi assez déstabilisation dans la
région sur la corée du nord
nous avons soutenu les efforts menés par
les états unis d'amérique pour permettre
l'engagement d'une négociation même si
les résultats tangibles ne sont pas
encore là ces initiatives étaient
importantes et ce que nous attendons à
présent ce sont des gestes d'engagement
concret de la part de la corée du nord
elle doit se conformer aux résolutions
du conseil de sécurité et s'engager
rapidement et de bonne foi dans un
processus de dénucléarisation complète
vérifiable et irréversible
c'est la seule voie possible pour
parvenir à une solution politique à une
paix durable sur la péninsule coréenne
c'est incontournable pour la stabilité
et la sécurité régionales comme pour la
paix et la sécurité internationales de
la même manière nous ne tolérerons pas
que des armes chimiques soit employé en
europe en russie comme en syrie au nom
de la sécurité collective
je redis ici à la russie la nécessité
que toute la lumière soit faite sur la
tentative d'assassinât contre un
opposant politique à l'aide d'un agents
neurotoxiques le nunchuk
cette clarification doit être rapide et
sans défaut car nous ferons respecter
nos lignes rouges
et en la matière la france a toujours
été au rendez-vous de l'effectivité des
lignes rouges fixées depuis que je suis
président de la république notre
sécurité collective c'est aussi la lutte
contre le terrorisme partout où cela est
nécessaire
la france a été touchée il y a plusieurs
années de manière répétée par le
terrorisme sur notre sol dans notre cher
avec des actes terroristes parfois
fomenté au coeur même à l'épicentre du
terrorisme islamiste je pense en
particulier aux attentats de 2015 conçu
en syrie c'est pourquoi la france sera
toujours fortement engagée au levant et
en appui à la souveraineté irakienne et
se tient aux côtés de ses partenaires
sails au levant nous continuerons d'être
engagée au sein de la coalition
internationale
nous avons eu une première victoire la
fin du califat territoriales cette
victoire ne marque pas la fin de la
guerre dans la région
nous continuerons de nous battre contre
tous les terroristes dans le cadre de la
coalition internationale et aux côtés de
thoune et part de tous nos partenaires
non je veux ici rappeler le rôle que les
combattants kurdes en syrie on tue aux
côtés de la coalition contre des ch et
les terroristes
je veux ici aussi rappelé le rôle
essentiel que l'irak et les irakiens ont
tué continue d'avoir dans ce combat
c'est pourquoi la france soutient avec
force toutes les initiatives que l'irak
prend aujourd'hui continuera de prendre
pour sa souveraineté et son rôle dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme au sahel
la france est comme vous le savez
profondément engagés aux côtés
principalement des cinq états sahéliens
et les sommer de pau puis de nouakchott
ont permis de poser les bases d'une
coalition pour renforcer dans cette
région la lutte contre nos deux ennemis
l'état islamique et al qaïda ces deux
organisations ont subi au cours des
derniers mois des revers sans précédent
les objectifs fixés dépôt de se
concentrer sur la zone des trois
frontières et loïc gs ont produit des
résultats tangibles et inégalée jusqu'à
lors nous poursuivrons ce travail avec
l'appui de barkan et de nos partenaires
européens et américains les armes et du
g5 sel ont repris l'aventage ont
réintégré des positions qui avaient été
perdues cette dynamique de se poursuivre
c'est le sens même de la coalition que
nous mettons en place ce qui vient de se
passer au mali au cours des dernières
semaines nous rappelle aussi une
évidence la démocratie et la lutte
contre le terrorisme vont de pair ces
deux combats ne sont pas séparables et
seule la démocratie la justice l'état de
droit le développement ramèneront une
paix durable au sahel
ce qu'ils ont fait irruption au mali au
nom de ces principes ne doivent pas
maintenant les trahir ils doivent mettre
le mali sur la voie irréversible du
retour à un pouvoir civil et
l'organisation d'élections rapides
la france comme ses partenaires
africains en particulier ne pourra
rester engagés qu'à cette condition
je le dis je leur dis très clairement
la france n'est présente sur le sol
malien comme sur le sol des autres pays
de la région qu'à la demande des états
souverains et des organisations
régionales
à la seconde où c&a souhaiteront notre
départ ou considérant qu'ils peuvent se
battre seul contre le terrorisme nous
nous retirons et c'est donc la
réitération de cette demande de ce
besoin notre engagement que j'ai demandé
à pau puis à nouakchott et qui a été
aussi confirmée par la junte au mali et
c'est sur ce sujet sur lequel nous
resterons extrêmement vigilant je crois
dans la souveraineté des peuples et je
pense que notre action contre le
terrorisme ne peut être utiles et
durables que s'il se conjugue avec le
respect de sa souveraineté
avec une démocratie effective et avec
une vraie politique de développement
celle aussi que nous avons conçu avec
l'alliance pour le sahel et qu'avec nos
partenaires européens africains avec la
banque mondiale aussi nous continuons de
développer pour des actions utiles sur
le terrain la deuxième priorité à mes
yeux des prochains mois c'est la
construction exigeante de la paix et de
la stabilité dans le respect de légal
souveraineté des peuples la grammaire de
la paix et de la stabilité est à
redéfinir parce que les lignes ont
profondément bouger à la faveur de la
crise nos fonds bien avant tel le
retrait américain qui faisait office de
garant en dernier ressort d'un système
international aujourd'hui dépassé
l'affirmation hégémonique d'autres
puissances à la faveur de ce
désengagement la projection de la chine
à l'extérieur de ses frontières
le renforcement de la souveraineté
européenne toutes ces tendances de fond
doivent nous conduire à repenser les
modalités de notre action collective
pour garantir la paix et la sécurité
le principe d'action à la matière
doivent être claires et notre main ne
doit plus tremblé dans leur application
le respect des droits souverains des
peuples la consolidation des états de
droit et de leurs moyens d'action
l'exigence et la responsabilité pour
assurer la mise en oeuvre effective des
décisions actées sous l'égide des
nations unies
c'est exactement ce que nous faisons au
liban où les aspirations du peuple
libanais souverain doivent être
respectés entendu et soutenu quoi qu'il
en soit des errements inacceptable de la
classe politique libanaise
je veux ici redire tout mon soutien pour
le peuple libanais et ma détermination à
agir de là où je suis et en plein
respect de la souveraineté libanaise
mais en amitié exigences comme je dis
souvent pour que le liban puisse se
redresser pour que la vie puisse
s'améliorer et pour qu'aussi le chemin
d'un apaisement d'une démocratie plus
effective soit trouvée mais le liban est
un trésor pour l'humanité tout entière
un trésor parce qu'il est une forme
d'exception de démocratie et de
pluralisme dans une région
bousculé par le terrorisme et les
puissances hégémoniques
les nations unies doivent être
concrètement comme elles l'ont été cet
été et dans la durée
engagé aux côtés de la société civile et
des ong pour faire face aux besoins
immédiats et engager la reconstruction
et là aussi nous ne lâcherons rien en
syrie la reprise des pourparlers à
genève sous l'égide des nations unies
est une étape positive
mais ce processus ne peut se limiter à
la rédaction d'une nouvelle constitution
il devra passer par la tenue d'élections
libres régulières et transparentes pour
respecter là aussi les aspirations et la
souveraineté du peuple syrien
la france et ses partenaires européens
continueront donc de conditionner le
financement de la reconstruction et la
normalisation des relations avec damas à
la mise en oeuvre d'une solution
politique crédible la seule durable la
seule qui permettra d'éradiquer le
terrorisme dans la région
la paix au proche orient reste une
nécessité
d'abord pour les israéliens et les
palestiniens mais pour nous tous
je me réjouis qu israël obtiennent la
reconnaissance de nouveaux pays arabes
c'est une reconnaissance légitime c'est
aussi un gage d'espoir pour l'avenir
pour autant
une paix juste et durable nécessite
avant tout de retrouver les voies et
moyens d'une négociation décisive qui
permette aux palestiniens de disposer
enfin de leurs droits il n'y a pas
d'alternative à une négociation
courageuse qui nécessitera de s'entendre
sur les questions les plus difficiles
dans le respect des aspirations
légitimes de chacun à une reconnaissance
pleine et entière à la sécurité et à la
souveraineté
je ne crois pas à une paix qui se
construira sur l'hégémonie ou
l'humiliation
quand bien même celles-ci seraient
compensés par de l'argent car nous
savons trop qu'on ne compense pas
l'humiliation d'un peuple par de
l'argent c'est à nous collectivement de
bâtir cette solution ambitieuse en libye
la crise a désormais un impact profond
sur la stabilité régionale et a été
aggravée par la multiplication des
ingérences extérieures
la libye est à mes yeux l'illustration
parfaite des erreurs auxquelles nous
pouvons conduire
nous pouvons nous même conduire
lorsqu'on respecte pas la souveraineté
des peuples
aucune puissance ne peut bâtir le bien
un peuple sans qu'il l'ait souhaitait et
construit lui même par les voix de
transition qu'il a souhaité aussi
aujourd'hui nous n'avons d'autre choix
que d'agir très concrètement c'est ce
que fait l'europe pour faire respecter
effectivement et par tous l'embargo sur
les armes décidé par les nations unies
cet embargo aujourd'hui et violée par
plusieurs puissances
cela n'est pas durable plusieurs
puissances aussi ont décidé de continuer
d'importer des combattants du théâtre
syrien exportant le terrorisme dans
cette région au mépris des intérêts de
la libye de ses voisins du sahel et de
l'ordre nous avons été collectivement
trop silencieux sur ses agissements et
nous devons être beaucoup plus dur dans
les semaines qui viennent
nous travaillons avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires dont les pays voisins de la
libye pour obtenir un cessez le feu
durable puis enclencher une dynamique
qui permette une résolution politique du
conflit sous l'égide des nations unies
ces initiatives que la france souhaite
conduire dans les prochaines semaines en
lien avec le secrétaire général des
nations unies réunir tous les pays
voisins pour aider à faire émerger la
solution libyenne ce réengagement du
voisinage libyen est indispensable dans
la durée en méditerranée orientale
il nous faut ré engager un dialogue
efficace et clarifier pour éviter un
nouvel espace de confrontation et de
remise en cause du droit international
les pays méditerranéens de l'union
européenne se sont exprimés clairement
en ce sens il ya quelques jours
ajaccio nous respectons la turquie nous
sommes prêts au dialogue avec elle mais
nous attendons qu'elle respecte la
souveraineté européenne le droit
international et apporte des
clarifications sur son action en libye
comme en syrie les insultes sont
inopérantes et toutes ces paroles et
tous ces actes n'ont pas leur place dans
des relations responsable entre état et
l'appel à la responsabilité que l'europe
a voulu lancer nous européens sommes
prêts au dialogue à la construction
indispensable d'une pax méditerranéen
mais pas au prix de l'intimidation pas
au prix de la logique du plus fort dans
le respect du droit international de la
coopération et du respect entre alliés
ces principes sont non négociables en
europe continentale sur la crise
ukrainienne le format normandie nous a
permis cette année avec la chancelière
fédérale d'allemagne d'obtenir deux
premières avancées mais la situation en
biélorussie comporte le risque d'une
nouvelle fracture sur notre continent
le courage du peuple biélorusse force
l'admiration de tous ses aspirations
doivent être respectées et nous sommes à
ses côtés je veux le dire avec beaucoup
de force
un dialogue politique national doit être
mise en place et toute intervention
extérieure doit être évité nous avons
l'occasion avec la chancelière
d'allemagne avec le président du conseil
d'échanger avec le président poutine
et de plaider
pour une médiation proposée par le fce
ne voyons pas d'autre chemin que celui
ci non à l'ingérence non silence
coupable
l'europe là aussi sera au rendez vous de
sa responsabilité de son histoire et de
sa géographie
mais croire à la paix et à la stabilité
dans notre région c'est aussi vouloir
bâtir pour l'europe continentale les
nouvelle grammaire en quelque sorte
d'une stabilité durable et celle ci ne
saurait se réduire
ni aux accords historiques ni au fond au
démantèlement de ces accords
durant les dernières années lorsqu'on
parle de paix de stabilité de sécurité
collectif pour l'europe
je ne peux pas taire aujourd'hui le fait
que nous vivons dans une situation notre
sécurité et stabilité dépend des très
largement d'accord signé jadis entre les
états unis d'amérique et lurs et que ces
accords ont progressivement été
démantelé durant la dernière décennie la
fin du traité est finie a marqué une
étape importante sur laquelle nous ne
devons rester silencieux c'est pourquoi
je souhaite que nous européens puissions
réengager le cadre d'une discussion
complète et ambitieuse avec tous nos
voisins pour notre sécurité collective
et construire le cadre nouveau qui
prenne en compte la fin de ces traités
historiques
je le dis aussi avec beaucoup de cartes
et nous ne délivrons pas notre sécurité
collective à d'autres puissances calais
troisièmement devons protéger les biens
qui nous sont comme cette notre
responsabilité à tous cela va au delà
nos intérêts nationaux de nos équilibres
régionaux protéger nos biens communs
n'est pas contradictoire avec l'exercice
de notre souveraineté
c'est au contraire la seule manière de
la préserver réellement en gardant le
contrôle de nos destins
c'est exactement ce que la crise que
nous traversons démontre une fois de
plus de manière incontestable la santé
d'un seul face à une épidémie c'est la
santé de tous
et nous avons une occasion unique de
faire des moyens de lutte contre la
pandémie des biens publics mondiaux
auxquels chacun devra avoir accès c'est
le sens de l'action que nous conduisons
dans le cadre d'actes à et nous que nous
consoliderons dans les prochains mois
sur l'ensemble des piliers notamment sur
le renforcement des systèmes de santé la
santé bien public mondial
c'est un combat que nous avons mené
durant toute l'année qui vient de
s'écouler que nous avions mené aussi à
lyon quand il s'est agi de re mobiliser
la communauté internationale pour
financer la lutte contre ces aides des
épidémies historique
c'est ce que nous continuerons de faire
et nous devons le donner plus de force
dans les mois qui viennent le climat et
la biodiversité doivent être plus que
jamais aussi au coeur d'un autre agenda
collectif pas dans les mots mais dans
les actes en décembre l'accord de paris
aura cinq ans et nous savons d'ores et
déjà que les objectifs que nous nous
étions collectivement fixe et ne
pourront pas être atteints
la réponse à la pandémie peut changer la
donne les plans de relance massifs
adoptés dans tous les pays sont une
occasion historique de transformation de
notre modèle économique et de
développement
cela doit être au coeur de l'ambition
l'union européenne et je remercie la
présidente de la commission qui s'est
fortement engagée cela doit être au
coeur des travaux du g7 et du g20
c'est indispensable c'est aussi pour
cela que je veux que la france puisse le
jour anniversaire des cinq ans d'accord
de paris mobiliser à nouveau la
communauté internationale afin chacune
et chacun d'entre nous de regarder où
nous en sommes nos engagements sans en
changer en quelque sorte la mesure sans
brouiller les cartes
mais en remobilisant très fortement
l'ensemble de nos pays et de nos régions
dans une transparence complète mais dans
un volontarisme qu'il faut renouveler
l'europe parviendra dans les prochaines
semaines j'y suis déterminé à un accord
pour réhausser le niveau de son ambition
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone en
la présidente de la commission
européenne a fixé l'objectif de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre à au moins 55 % en 2030
cela suppose d'aller plus vite plus fort
sur un os ts ambitieux un prix du
carbone minimum un mécanisme d'inclusion
carbone aux frontières
l'ensemble de ces mesures constituent un
tout l'une sans les autres n'auraient
pas la même efficacité aux côtés de nos
partenaires britanniques et européens
nous irons chercher sur cette base un
par un les engagements des grands
émetteurs en vue de la coop 26 et nous
serons aux côtés de nos partenaires
notamment africains pour atteindre nos
objectifs communs le rendez-vous de
descendre sur ce chemin sera essentielle
en novembre nous réunirons à paris un
sommet des banques de développement pour
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des flux
financiers contribuer à une relance
écologique et solidaire en ligne avec
l'accord de paris sur la biodiversité
dont les liens avec le changement
climatique comme la santé humaine sont
désormais établies nous organiserons
dans les prochains mois à marseille avec
les nations unies avec la banque
mondiale
un one planet ce mythe qui nous
permettra de bâtir un agenda d'actions
concrètes sur les aires protégées
terrestres et marines l'agroécologie le
financement de la biodiversité et la
lutte contre la déforestation la
protection aussi des écosystèmes et des
espèces les océans l'épaule les forêts
tropicales appartiennent au patrimoine
commun de l'humanité nous devons les
protéger et nous le ferons en vue des
échéances décisives que seront pour les
nations unies
les coptes climat biodiversité et lutte
contre la désertification pour être au
rendez vous je vous propose qu'un sommet
soit organisée l'an prochain à new york
en amont de ces trois coques pour leur
donner une impulsion décisive et aboutir
à des résultats tangibles
l'espace numérique est aussi un bien
commun un bien commun unique ouvert et
de confiance qui doit faire l'objet
d'une gouvernance nouvelle pour éviter
qu'ils ne soient captés pirate est
instrumentalisée
c'est le sens des initiatives que nous
portons dans
le cadre du partenariat informations et
démocratie de l'appel de christchurch
ainsi que du partenariat mondial sur
l'intelligence artificielle
nous devons consolider chacun de ces
partenariats avancé aussi sur le
processus d'aqaba et je remercie
l'engagement de la première ministre néo
zélandaise comme du roi de jordanie sur
cet agenda
ce sont maintenant des solutions
concrètes mais surtout maintenant nous
avons besoin pas simplement des
engagements des actions des grands
opérateurs des actions des grandes
plateformes et d'un engagement de notre
part à tous à légiférer à réglementer au
niveau de nos régions
s'ils ne sont pas au rendez vous des
engagements pris la lutte contre la
haine la lutte contre le terrorisme la
création au fond d'un nain l'ordre
public commun de l'internet sont aussi
importants que l'innovation
technologique et que la liberté car il
n'y a pas de liberté sans ordre public
c'est à nous de le créer par un
engagement international et je ne crois
pas que la protection de la liberté
d'expression puisse s'accomoder du
discours terroristes des discours de
haine de l'anonymat qui couvre en
quelque sorte la désinhibition de la
violence cet agenda est essentiel pour
nous tous et toutes nous continuerons
d'y agir avec force
enfin et je le dis dans un contexte qui
est celui de l'épidémie que je rappelais
l'éducation est un bien commun essentiel
sur lequel nous continuerons nous
engager dans l'année qui vient
des centaines de millions de nos jeunes
ont été sortis de l'éducation à cause de
l'épidémie
mais l'éducation en particulier
l'éducation des jeunes filles continuent
d'être une priorité tout
particulièrement en afrique
aux côtés du président macky sall nous
nous sommes engagés pour le partenariat
mondial pour l'éducation
nous avons levé des fonds nouveaux afin
de financer les actions de ce
partenariat le rôle aujourd'hui de la
banque mondiale
des nations unies du partenariat mondial
pour l'éducation de l'unesco le rôle
aussi de nos actions bilatérales doivent
être renforcées afin d'agir plus
efficacement encore dans les mois et les
années qui viennent pour améliorer
l'éducation et tout particulièrement
l'éducation des jeunes filles
ce combat n'est pas terminé loin de là
et nous ne serions l'oublier il est au
coeur en tout cas de l'engagement
français en matière de défense et de
lutte pour les biens publics mondiaux
le quatrième priorité fait la
construction d'une nouvelle ère de la
mondialisation
la première ère de la mondialisation fut
ouverte par les voyage de christophe
colomb de magellan celle de la
découverte des premières invasions aussi
d'un tâtonnement en quelque sorte d'une
forme de fascination ou parfois de
malentendus réciproque
la seconde fut celle des empires
coloniaux et de la révolution
industrielle du 19e siècle ce fut la
mondialisation par le commerce
les premières ouvertures mais aussi les
routes de l' esclavage de l'exploitation
et du développement des seins de
l'asservissement des autres des premiers
déplacements de population et d'une
recomposition de notre monde à l'aune de
ces domination la troisième a commencé
en 1989 avec la chute du mur de berlin
l'ouverture des frontières la croix cyan
de la croyance en la possibilité que la
circulation des biens et des personnes
puis la généralisation de l'internet
conduisent à des convergences d'intérêts
de valeur d'idées au fond c'est en cette
ère de la mondialisation
je passe là en cavalcade on pourrait
séparer chacune de ces aires en bien
d'autres période mais c'est cette
troisième ère qui a été remise en cause
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
parce que la conviction profonde la
téléologie qui l'accompagnait c'était
que cette mondialisation sur une
modélisation de la paix un rapprochement
des valeurs une universalisation du
respect de l'autre
elle a été remise en cause par la crise
financière les transformations du monde
le retour des peuples des consciences
nationales et enfin la pandémie mondiale
remise en cause aussi par une crise
profonde la crise des classes moyennes
occidentales qui à un moment ont douté
de ce que cet ordre nouveau de ce que
certains avaient pu appeler cette
mondialisation heureuse pouvait le
rappeler ces classes moyennes qui
partout en occident souvent été les
variables d'ajustement économique puis
culturelle de ce monde ainsi ouvert
alors ils seraient infondées en quelque
sorte de deniers tout ce que cette
période a permis de faire d'avancé tout
ce que cette troisième ère de la
mondialisation a permis d'apporter en
termes de prospérité elle a sorti des
centaines de millions de personnes de la
grande pauvreté précisément par une
redistribution du commerce et de la
production mondiale et l'ouverture a
permis une prise de conscience des
voyages des circulations qui ont aussi
pacifié pour partie nos relations et il
serait dangereux de nous enfermer dans
un bégaiement de l'histoire dans un
protectionnisme généralisé à coups de
droits de douane de guerre commerciale
dans une espèce de doute qui nous
conduirait au renfermement où est la
logique des puissances parce qu'on le
voit bien le risque c'est de répondre à
cette crise de la mondialisation par un
repli nationaliste par la violence des
populismes des extrêmes plus tôt et par
le retour des puissances mais il est
clair que les chaînes de valeur
mondiales doivent être aujourd'hui
repenser parce que la crise a démontré
que la dépendance sur des secteurs
stratégiques tels que la santé le
numérique l'intelligence artificielle
l'alimentation aussi peuvent remettre en
question dans le monde tel qu'il est le
libre exercice de la souveraineté mais
nous avons aussi vu qu' il y a des
bonnes dépendance et il ya des
dépendances qui nous fragilise
nous avons besoin de garder le commerce
international et les ouvertures parce
que c'est bon pour nous sur le plan
économique et social
parce que nous ne saurions d'ailleurs
tout ré internaliser parce que cela
conduit à des justes dépendance qui
impose la coopération mais la dépendance
complète à l'égard de certaines
puissances qu'elles soient
technologiques qu'elle soit alimentaire
ou industriels créent des vulnérabilités
qui ne permet plus les équilibres qui
vont avec l'ordre du monde
ensuite les inégalités de ce nouvel
ordre mondial sont devenues
insoutenables
nous avons sorti des mythes des
centaines de millions de personnes de la
grande pauvreté dans certains pays nous
avons réduit pour partie des inégalités
nord-sud mais nous avons creusé les
inégalités au sein de nos pays et ce
nouvel ordre en insoutenable
démocratiquement le cours des choses tel
qu'il va puis nous avons créé une mode
et nous mondialisation des consciences
qui est aujourd'hui une mondialisation
en quelque sorte non plus du savoir qui
était le sous jacent d'internet mais qui
est devenue une mondialisation de
l'émotion et du ressentiment sur chacune
de ces crises nous devons apporter une
réponse
c'est cette stratégie dans l'union
européenne est en train de se doter
comme d'autres puissances il est
impératif que nos règles internationales
soit adapté pour tenir compte de ces
nouvelles réalités nous doter des moyens
d'une coopération internationale plus
équilibrée qui se fasse dans le respect
la souveraineté de chacun au bénéfice de
tous à cet égard la lutte contre les
inégalités devra être très clairement au
coeur de cette mondialisation repenser
la france apporté des initiatives qui
ont permis des résultats sur
l'entrepreneuriat féminin sur le
partenariat mondial pour l'éducation sur
la santé pour tous pour lutter contre
toutes les inégalités de destin mais il
faudra aller plus loin en quelque sorte
vous le voyez bien ce monde dans lequel
nous avons vécu reposer sur une un
consensus académique devenu un consensus
politique et de marché ce qu'on a
souvent appelé le consensus de
washington il a vécu nous devons reposer
ensemble les bases d'une mondialisation
plus juste plus équilibrée plus
équitable plus durable nous devons
penser les termes d'une mondialisation
qui accepte de revenir et de repenser
les termes d'une juste souveraineté et
du juste échange
qui intègre en son sein au coeur de son
modèle la lutte contre les inégalités
sous toutes leurs formes qu'elles soient
de genre de conditions ou économique
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et pour la biodiversité et
qui permettent de manière durable
d'intégrer les conditions d'un nouvel
équilibre du monde nous aurons là aussi
apporter des propositions concrètes dans
quelques semaines au forum de paris et
le travail engagé avec la commission
européenne avec le fonds monétaire
international et beaucoup d'autres
puissances de bonne volonté sera
essentiel à cet égard l'afrique sera
avec l'europe le moteur de cette
redéfinition des termes de la
mondialisation
c'est pourquoi nous continuerons nos
efforts dans le cadre de l'initiative
que nous avons construite pour aider les
pays africains à faire face à la
pandémie sur le plan sanitaire
économique social et humanitaire
le g20 de novembre sera un rendez vous
décisif pour la mise en oeuvre du
moratoire sur la dette que nous avons
acté et pour aller plus loin nous devons
aussi mieux accompagner les immenses
énergie des sociétés civiles de cette
jeunesse du continent qui est sa force
et son avenir c'est le sens des
initiatives que nous porterons dans les
prochains mois avec les diasporas et un
soutien au secteur privé africain
enfin le cinquième objectif que je veux
ici seuil est de proposer à notre
collectif c'est le respect du droit
international humanitaire et des droits
fondamentaux de chacun pour moi cet
objectif est essentiel à la survie même
de notre organisation
en effet nous assistons dans ce domaine
à une série de reculs bien souvent trop
de silence depuis la création par les
nations unies d'une journée mondiale
humanitaire cinq mille travailleurs ont
été victimes d'attaqués 10 800 ont été
assassinés l'année dernière a été la
plus meurtrière et j'ai une pensée toute
particulière pour
ces jeunes françaises et français qui au
sein de l'organisation acte aide devrait
exactement dans ce cadre au niger et ont
été tués dans des conditions atroces
mois d'août dernier
non les nations unies ne peuvent pas
rester inactif devant une telle
régression
c'est pourquoi avec les ong françaises
avec nos partenaires internationaux nous
construisons une initiative pour assurer
l'effectivité du droit international la
protection du personnel humanitaire et
la lutte contre l'impunité
l'espace humanitaire est un patrimoine
commun qu'il nous faut protéger en
garantissant l'accès aux populations
civiles comme la protection des
personnels qui les soutiennent nous
avons vu des reculs sur ce sujet
inexcusable
nous avons vu des pratiques y compris de
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité en syrie en particulier
inacceptable la neutralité de l'action
humanitaire doit être respectée et sa
criminalisation endiguer prendre nos
responsabilités dans le domaine
humanitaire
c'est aussi faire preuve de solidarité
et d'humanité dans le domaine migratoire
la situation en grèce amoria est
aujourd'hui très difficile la france aux
côtés de l'allemagne et de ses
partenaires prendra ses responsabilités
pour accueillir les réfugiés et nous
devons agir tous ensemble dans la
gestion des flux migratoires pour mettre
fin au trafic d'êtres humains aux
traversées de la mort aux routes de la
nécessité ce sera au coeur de l'agenda
européen des prochaines semaines j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
nous devons intensifier la lutte contre
ces trafiquants et être au rendez vous
de nos responsabilités enfin les droits
fondamentaux ne sont pas une idée
occidentale que l'on pourrait opposer
comme une ingérence à tous ceux qui s'y
réfèrent ce sont des principes de notre
organisation inscrits dans des textes
que les états membres des nations unies
ont librement consenti à signer et à
respecter
c'est la raison pour laquelle notamment
la france a demandé qu'une mission
internationale sous l'égide des nations
unies puissent se rendre au xing yang
afin de prendre en compte les
préoccupations que nous avons
collectivement
sur la situation de la minorité
musulmane ouïghoure et c'est parce que
nous ne pouvons pas tolérer que 25 ans
après la conférence de pékin les droits
des femmes dans le monde connaisse un
profond recul que nous organiserons
l'été prochain le forum génération
égalité avec onu femmes avec la société
civile pour l'émancipation de toutes
l'éducation des filles et le respect
réel et effectif des droits de l'homme
voilà les cinq principes sur lesquels la
france veut reconstruire avec vous les
fondements de l'ordre international pour
que les fondements de notre organisation
ne soit pas emporter par la pandémie
au contraire il faut prendre le
changement par la main avant qu'il ne
nous prennent par la gorge disait
winston churchill
cela nécessite en méthode
l'établissement d'une coopération
internationale fonctionnel fondé sur des
règles claires défini et respecté par
tous le multilatéralisme n'est pas
seulement un acte de foi
c'est une nécessité opérationnel aucun
pays ne se sortira seul de cette épreuve
la coopération internationale peut être
difficile mais elle est objectivement
impérative pour autant ne pouvons plus
nous contenter d'un multilatéralisme des
mots qui me permet de d'agréer que le au
fond le plus grand dénominateur commun
manière de masquer des divergences
profondes sous un consensus de façade
il faut changer de méthode inverser les
termes du contrat être aussi haut et
clair quand certains se piquent
d'adhérer à des alliances et à leurs
principes à des organisations dans leur
principe pour les foulées aux pieds au
réel soyons honnêtes entre nous lucide
exigeant le multilatéralisme
contemporain doit aussi associer les
organisations internationales les
acteurs privés les entreprises les ong
des chercheurs les citoyens pour que
chacun soit partie prenante des actions
engagées
il se construira sur la base d'accords
solide respecter vérifier entre
partenaires de bonne foi autour
d'objectifs et de règles claires avec
une vraie responsabilité et des
mécanismes de redevabilité
c'est pourquoi au forum de paris pour la
paix en novembre nous nous efforcerons
avec nos partenaires européens et
africains avec tous ceux qui le
souhaitent en asie en amérique et
ailleurs de consolider les bases de ce
nouveau consensus international au
bénéfice de l'avenir de notre
organisation
je ne crois pas au grand jour de
refondation je crois en un travail
déterminé méthodique rigoureux de
construction d'un ordre international
contemporain qui permettra de tenir les
générations futures à l'écart du fléau
de la guerre d' affirmer les droits de
l'homme et l'égalité entre les nations
de favoriser le progrès social dans une
liberté plus grande
c'est la promesse même de notre charte
elle est d'actualité
je crois en la force de la volonté en la
valeur de la sincérité et du courage et
en vous parlant en ce moment même malgré
la distance que crée l'écran j'ai en
mémoire le regard d'une enfant libanaise
rencontré il ya quelques jours qu'ils
avaient tout perdu tout perdu mais qui
avait fait le serment de se battre
envers et contre tout pour ce en quoi
elle croit
c'est la même mémoire pour les jeunes
français assassinés au niger parce
qu'ils croyaient en un monde d'humanité
de solidarité et de fraternité mais
c'est le même souvenir que beaucoup
d'entre vous ont sûrement et doivent
savoir qu'ils nous obligent qui nous
oblige à agir et qui nous interdit le
cynisme qui nous oblige qui nous oblige
à agir et qui nous interdit le
découragement ou la facilité il y a des
vies mais il ya surtout des jeunes
filles des jeunes garçons qui partout
dans le monde s'engage parce qu'ils
croient à nos maux parce qu'ils vivent
pour et par nos principes
si nous les trahit son nous sommes les
premiers coupables de leur désillusion
ou du fait qu'il perde tout alors c'est
à nous de faire jeu nous ans est capable
en tout cas là où nous sommes
nous ferons tout pour agir et je sais
que beaucoup de collègues ils sont près
aussi je compte sur chacune et chacun
d'entre vous merci